[Music]
I'm Jeff glor from CBS Saturday morning
welcome to the dish
from Royal recipes to celebrity
cookbooks we're bringing you an episode
full of our favorite Chef's culinary
creations
we start here in New York City where
basketball Superstar Shaquille O'Neal
tells CBS morning's anchor Gail King
about his first cookbook you could call
these Comfort Foods a slam dunk
foreign
's accomplishments both on and off the
court have turned him into a massive
brand but now another long time passion
is taking Center Stage
you say in this book you're 7-1 325
pounds size 22 shoe so you said I know a
thing or two about eating what do you
know
I know that Dr Lucille O'Neal my mother
even though we didn't have a lot
she made us feel like we had a lot I'm a
big guy I would always ask for seconds
and third and she'd be like man I hope
when you get older you have a good job
good job check and now Shaq is sharing
some of the meals he grew up loving at
home with a Twist in his first cookbook
Shaq's family style Championship recipes
for feeding family and friends it
includes 80 Comfort foods with lots of
flavor you open the book and you say
everybody should sort of pump yourself
up you said you should look in the
mirror let the crowd call your name
and say you should pump yourself up what
is your pump yourself up speech that you
give yourself
don't burn the house down
don't burn the house down and pay
attention to what I'm doing because like
in the kitchen like you really have to
pay attention like what sometimes when
I'm in the kitchen even though I'm 50
years old these guys treat me like I'm a
little kid hey man turn around you're
gonna burn the restaurant down Shaq has
known his executive chefs Matthew
Silverman and Matthew piekarski for over
20 years
teamed up to draft recipes that even the
self-proclaimed world's largest 11 year
old can follow tell us about the grilled
cheese Shack
this grilled cheese cheese
sandwiches
there's some pickled onions great
question Dale we tried those barbecued
pulled pork grilled cheese sandwiches
yum bacon wrap meatloaf glazed with
grape jelly
you like grape jelly they said but we
could not miss one of Shaq's favorites
cheddar crust chicken pot pie and a
comfort food that put me out of my
comfort zone there's just something
about the texture of grits that bothers
me Carolina barbecue shrimp and buttery
cheese grits these are good in the book
there's like five or six ingredients and
it's a it's a great cajun spice say I
came over on a Saturday night what would
we be eating what else is going on
basketball game I like a basketball how
about a nice rom-com you like rom-coms
excuse me
I was gonna ask you romantic romantic
comments okay okay so movie night yeah
okay first we get there and we have some
champagne yeah welcome Gail hold on is
this a date or are we just friends we're
just we're just friends okay we're good
friends okay so champagne should it be a
date I don't know you're too young for
me this girl
that's true I'm too young for you okay
what's what's the main entree that
you're serving big chicken uh-huh
broccoli
maybe some macaroni no I have to say
guys I don't notice a lot of vegetables
up here what is your thinking with that
check I don't eat a lot of vegetables go
you don't no
should you eat more vegetables I don't
have to I'm I'm pretty strong and pretty
fit you do seem to have made the
transition from basketball your
basketball life to your next chapter I
mean so many players are not able to
successfully make the transition did you
have a game plan
I know a question you're asking me and
the answer is I had to
when I was coming up my parents did a
great job of showing me negative stories
six percent of NBA players lose
everything when they're done
educate yourself
financial literacy don't do this I come
home with the big chains and the
Diamonds take it back save your money
save your money save your money and so
when you look at your own children you
have six children what was your message
to them about money and what it meant
and what they
deserved or were entitled to well now
that they're older and they get mad when
I say this I always tell them we're not
rich I'm rich that's just a you know
keep them well grounded we teach them
about respect
teaching about honor I teach them about
following their dreams
what gives you the greatest joy these
days my family my mother when I talk to
people they say why are you always happy
I said because I limit my stress
I have what's known as one hand stress
what does that mean the things I only
worry about is my mother
my children
my businesses myself I don't even get
the five if it's not one of these four
it doesn't bother me yeah you think
about your legacy
you're still young I know what my legacy
is already oh okay Cher a juvenile
delinquent that listened to his parents
and followed all his dreams period and
Shaquille O'Neal still dreams big this
is the thing about you Shack you have a
business career DJing which you clearly
love I've seen you you clearly loved to
do music music and sports are the only
thing that can bring people together no
matter what's going on it also gives me
that adrenaline boost that I've been
missing for the last 11 years you missed
the game oh I just missed a for an hour
DJ diesel
what would be the song you'd play for me
I slowed the music down and I'd be like
this song is dedicated to the lovely gay
okay did you ever know that you were my
hair
what would be a fun song you'd play for
me
one of my favorite Parts is you said
it's not over till dessert
it's not over until banana pudding is
served so you and I have to disagree
though because I believe banana pudding
should be warm you believe banana
pudding should be let's go cold do you
believe it should be cold see you hear
that that's the banana pudding police
that right there is the banana pudding
police okay you said that
vanilla pudding cold America banana
pudding warm America cold
after the break a taste of decades-old
recipes from a South Carolina Chef this
is the dish
foreign
is a household name in the small town of
Edisto Island South Carolina after
decades in the kitchen she published her
first cookbook at the age of 89 her food
celebrate her West and Central African
culture jarika Duncan took a bite
when Emily maggot's kitchen doors open
it's a welcome sign to anyone looking
for a home-cooked meal so you have an
open door policy Open Door walk right in
all you have to do is think a little
flower on it maggot or miss Emily as
she's known around Edisto Island Cooks
daily and she's always prepared to serve
extra whether for one or in this case
100 my grandmother said don't never cook
this enough for you all of these cooked
more because you don't know who's going
to walk in that door wow it's good
there's something about this chicken on
this small island of about 2 000 people
everyone seems to know Miss Emily in
fact the owner of the local market
doesn't charge her for anything because
Damaris you'll have squash for us a
biscuits or cornbread she's dead in my
heart and many others in this region
she's um
One of a Kind local Chef B.J Dennis
considers her the matriarch of this
community the history the food the
culture all that is wrapped up in Emily
Megan so Edison Island Emily Mega just
go hand in hand
we spent some time with Miss Emily in
her kitchen and watched as she prepared
casserole baked chicken that's it no
what's the magic and red rice now how do
you know how much to use
imagination in your brain and your heart
from okra to yellow squash salt pork and
seafood Miss Emily's galagichi culture
has influenced all of her cuisines
this is good it's a culture that goes
back to her enslaved ancestors whose
experience growing rice in Africa
allowed South Carolina's low country's
economy to flourish to this day red rice
is a Gullah staple where does your love
for cooking come from my grandmother was
a cook and she taught me how to cook
because I didn't like going out on the
field to Earth so she would say you stay
home and you cook clean the house
and then bring us our lunch at the age
of 22 Emily took a job at this Mansion
she washed dishes for the Dodge family
earning just 11.15 a week it was fun
it was fun yes it was yeah
until
I had to do that cooking what was the
hardest dish for you to get right when
you first started really Biscuit the
biscuit was the toughest one oh I
couldn't get that biscuit right for
nothing but the head cook at the house a
Gullah woman named Julia Brown helped
maggot with a dash of tough love if I
didn't do it right
she would throw it in the garbage can
she said you're gonna do it right and if
you don't do it right you're gonna do it
over again and I did it over over and
over and over but I got it right she
spent nearly 50 years working there 12
hour days all while she and her late
husband Jesse raised 11 children how did
you do it despite the grace of the good
Lord when the Mansion was sold miss
Emily spent Summers cooking for Becky
Smith and her family she has this
amazing ability to make the cooking look
like it's just nothing effortless and
she can do it and talk and give you
stories and wisdom and engage I just
thought this is one incredible woman and
just said to her Emily the world needs
to know you about two decades ago Smith
began encouraging miss Emily to write a
cookbook but that meant reverse
engineering nearly 200 dishes taking
recipes from Miss Emily's imagination
and putting them to paper the result
Miss Emily's life her cooking and
culture all boiled down to this 282-page
book
the community through a party for their
favorite cook turned Arthur with people
lining up not for a meal but for an
autograph it was amazing
it's the most wonderful thing to see
someone who's lived her life
just in such a quiet yet powerful way be
so honored it's the most wonderful thing
to witness
[Applause]
[Music]
volunteer service Lifetime Achievement
Award you did it all we are just so
grateful to God but what he has done at
this beautiful age of 89
. she never imagined her cooking would
lead to this but when love is baked into
everything you serve there's always a
craving for more
Cara Harris is a self-taught cook who
brings old recipes to life in the
kitchen and online where she writes
about them on her blog Old Line plates
Nicole Killian sat down with Cara in
Charm City to learn more about her
culinary Journey
add one cup sugar one cup of butter six
eggs breeding recipes boil all well
together and seal while hot is food for
Kara Harris's Soul how did this culinary
Adventure begin I found these recipes
that had Maryland in the title like
Maryland's white potato pie the only way
to try them was to go ahead and make
them myself when did you find out when
you tried that very first dish I found
out that I wasn't very good at making
pie crust we dished at the Paper Moon
Diner a funky retro Style Cafe in her
Baltimore neighborhood
where over the past decade the
self-taught cook has figured out not
only how to make pie crust but a whole
lot more
the Maryland native has transformed her
foodie fascination of unearthing
Hometown dishes into the blog Old Line
plate with a database of more than 40
000 recipes Baltimore caramels
essentially a recipe for fudge a vinegar
candy and Maryland Fried Chicken deviled
crab she's taken local cookbooks dating
back decades and methodically mapped out
the origin of each recipe Harris's
extensive research comes from her
collection of 200 cookbooks and long
hours at Baltimore's historic Pratt
Library to discover and ultimately share
the history of some of America's most
iconic and long-lost Foods this is a
hobby for you is it a passion I guess
both I see it as a hobby I tell people
that it's like building model cars I
want to continually get better at it
like baking this Victorian inspired rose
geranium cake from 1910. this cake
sounded interesting because it involves
these geranium leaves so there's not
actually roses in the recipe because
that's what I thought were you
um yeah a lot of old recipes were
flavored with rose before vanilla caught
on we're adding we're adding one cup of
water sometimes it can be a mix a trial
and error so they just contain a little
bit of extra air
foreign
they give you the biggest of
instructions and you just have to know
what to do from there
[Music]
this is very delicious it's very light
here we go in other instances it's a
matter of going straight to the source
but mama know how to get on that stove
and just work it like when Cara Tracked
Down Bertha hunt after Chronicle a
centuries-old family recipe for southern
Maryland stuffed ham what did you think
when you first got that call asking for
your recipe
I was shocked and this means a lot to me
it's been from generation to generation
to generation and with me with my mom
and it came down from slavery
you must remember my great-grandmother
was a slave I put the Cabbage the kale
and the onions then I put my seasonings
you stuff it the rabbit
I bought it you must have finished
product right there
I hope it's not too hot for you I really
do
um
this is very flavorful season with salt
and pepper but to get a true taste for
why Cara does this it's a lot more than
finding these recipes
finding the people too I don't own the
recipes but I love connecting with
people about the food that means a lot
to them and that's the key ingredient
while boiling add a pinch of allspice a
few Blades of Mace
coming up we head across the pond to
have a cup of tea with a former Royal
Chef
stay with us
[Music]
Carolyn Robb was appointed the first
female personal chef to Prince Charles
and Princess Diana in 1989. Roxanna
saberi went to the English Countryside
to chat with her about her latest
cookbook tea at the palace
at home in the English Countryside
Carolyn Robb recreates sweet memories it
is like art isn't it
it is yes really simple ingredients um
but presentation counts with so much
inspired by the places she used to live
it's beautiful and work the South
African Chef perfected her skills at
Kensington Palace a residence for
generations of royalty and where she
landed her first job at age 21 right out
of culinary school you must have had a
very good job reference I was the lucky
one they were impressed I think so yes
as part of her training Rob got a crash
course in Royal protocol what are some
of those protocols the first time you
see a member of the royal family each
day you can't see to them
um which can be a bit awkward if you're
in the kitchen with a potato peeler in
your hand
s hide it behind exactly
two years later she got the top job at
the palace
as the first female personal chef to
Prince Charles and Princess Diana and
their sons William and Harry how
intimidating was it to work for the
prince and princes of Wales I was so
inspired by the job I just threw myself
into it and didn't didn't stop to think
about the daunting side of it Rob was at
Kensington Palace in 1997 when the young
princes had to deal with the untimely
death of their mother there was very
little that anybody certainly in my
position could really do but to know
that the food was the best it could
possibly be and the fact that the
kitchen was always a warm and happy and
welcoming Place Rob aims to bring the
comfort of cooking to everyone's home
with 50 recipes to celebrate the very
British tradition of afternoon tea
the ritual is marked in style every
summer at the Queen's Garden parties
where the Monarch invites thousands of
members of the public to tea a Victoria
sandwich is something that would always
be served at a garden party it's a very
simple sponge butter sugar eggs flour
some vanilla would began in the 1840s as
a mid-afternoon slice of cake when one
of Queen Victoria's ladies in Waiting
complained of a Sinking Feeling while
waiting for dinner has evolved into what
can be an elaborate Feast let's try
these meringues that you've prepared the
creme fraiche with the fruit hopefully
cuts through the sweetness of the
meringue a little
you used to make these with the princes
yes they love a piping bag full of
meringue and some of it ended up on the
tray and in the oven yeah
with a range of sweet delights from
melting moment biscuits to cacao date
and almond nuggets
um dates pack a punch they do
Rob hopes her royal recipes do more than
just satisfy a sweet tooth I hope it's
just all part of a bigger experience
spending time with family and friends
and enjoying some some treats something
a bit special something that you don't
have every single day
foreign
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 streamus
right here on CBS News I'm Jeff glor
thanks for watching the dish
[Music]